avec nous maintenant michel leblanc qui
est le pdg de la chambre de commerce du
montréal métropolitain reçoit michel
leblanc bonsoir la zone rouge donc pour
montréal pour les territoires de
montréal de montérégie laval laurentides
et de lanaudière
ça ça demeure d'abord comment vous
accueilli cette nouvelle ce soir
ben écoute et deux choses la première
c'est je pense que c'était prévisible
tout le monde qui regarde les chiffres
voit bien que d'abord montréal laval
s'est encore nettement zone rouge
et même dans la grande région on le voit
très bien on est dans cette zone là où
c'est fragile deuxièmement sa fille une
logique à le faire sur une base
métropolitaine les gens auraient des
comportements de déplacement si on
essayait de découper la zone donc c'est
une logique et troisièmement ce qu'on
retient aussi c'est le message de
prudence parce qu'on est dans cette
période où il ya la semaine de relâche
parce qu'il ya encore beaucoup
d'inconnues
mais en même temps le milieu des
affaires suit très attentivement la
dynamique de la vaccination et la tue
les gouvernements ont énormément de
pression mais l'on voit les chiffres qui
augmente à la fois les arrivages de
vaccins la dynamique de vaccination
elle-même donc de ce point de vue la
gérer au mieux les affaires faire la
part des choses
maintenant mon caveau à tous ces
commerces tous ces restaurants tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pas ouvrir
c'est extrêmement difficile et est ce
qu'on est capable de prévoir les ts que
les acteurs économiques de montréal
peuvent prévoir une reprise une saison
touristique pour l'été c'est le grand
défi et moi j'encourage tout le monde à
planifier un été qui va éventuellement
être des confiné on le voit les vaccins
arrivent les vaccins vont se vendre dans
les gens vont être vaccinés on regarde
comment ça se passe en israël puis
j'attire l'attention sur le fait qu
israël il ya une semaine décrété que si
on voyage il y en a il n'y a plus de 40
est non au retour tout simplement de par
son intérêt pour montrer qu'on apporte
l'aco vide et donc dans les fêtes ce
qu'on voit c'est que là où la campagne
de vaccination est en avance sur nous de
déconfinement haut lieu
la réouverture aux lieux et l'activité
économique en plomb la plus normale
reprend donc c'est très encourageant
pour l'été prochain la question ça va
être plutôt la saison touristique
appelons-la canadienne québécoise
pourrait-elle reprendre dès juillet ou
si ce sera plutôt en nous mais on peut
se préparer à ça si les vaccins sont
donnés on va trouver un semblant de
normalité ce qu'il est possible de
prévoir des festivals à montréal cet été
c'est une excellente question je pense
qu'on va vouloir se rencontrer je pense
qu'il va y avoir des activités
extérieures
je pense qu'on va trouver les solutions
pour faire en sorte que en juillet on
puisse fêter en ou sûrement et moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on va vivre un été qui
va se prolonger en septembre genou
prévoit qu'en septembre on aura des
activités de groupe à l'extérieur
encore une fois il faut regarder comment
ça se passe là où on vaccine plus vite
qu'ici pour s'apercevoir que normal on
s'en va vers cette normalité
au royaume uni le premier ministre boris
johnson a annoncé un calendrier un de
réouverture avec le 21 juin
tout est reparti le président va et
donne aux états unis dit les adultes
pourront être vaccinées d'ici la fin mai
est ce que vous aimeriez avoir un tel
calendrier une telle prévisibilité chez
nous aussi
oui et on le demande est ce qu'on
s'attend c'est que dans deux trois
semaines
les gouvernements vont le faire je pense
qu' il fallait être
il fallait voir les volumes de vaccins y
arriver il fallait voir si le dispositif
de vaccination pouvait se mettre en
place
vous avez dit plus tôt je pense les
pharmacies sont au rendez vous il ya
beaucoup d'acteurs privés qui vont
contribuer à ce qu'on soit capable de
vacciner le dernier enjeu évidemment qui
reste c'est la question de à quel moment
est ce que vous l'avez dit c'est dès
juin c'est en juillet mais moi je pense
que le milieu des affaires va s'attendre
à ce que les gouvernements précise les
conditions de réouverture incluant la
réouverture des frontières peut-être que
le vrai débat qui s'en viennent dans les
trois prochaines semaines c'est la
fameuse question de l'application qui va
être comme un espèce de certificat de
vaccination est ce qu'on devrait revoir
ça il ya beaucoup de gens nommés
je pense qu'on doit avoir ce certificat
de façon à rassurer les gens quand on
rouvrir les activités que dans les ont
privés c'est sécuritaire que tout le
monde qui a accès et vaccinés donc ça va
être une discussion à avoir un
certificat de vaccination une sorte de
passeport vaccination pour voyager mais
pour rentrer au restaurant aller au
spectacle
jusqu'où on va alors pour voyager je
pense qu'on aura pas de choix les autres
pays vont nous l'imposer à partir du
moment où on ne loue ti pour qu'on s'en
servirait pas localement et si c'est ça
que ça prend pour avoir vingt mille
personnes au centre bell en disant au
centre bell pour y avoir accès il faut
démontrer qu'ils ont été vaccinées
peut-être qu'on irla collectivement ça
sera le prix à payer de dire on veut un
retour à la normalité et ce retour à la
normalité
ça passe par un geste qu'on doit tous
faire par solidarité c'est se faire
vacciner
est ce qu'il ya et je termine là dessus
des problèmes structurels qui sont en
train de se former dans l'économie de
montréal en ce moment c'est le
centre-ville on va avoir une année de
travail à faire pour rétablir une forme
de normalité d'achalandage de retour des
travailleurs éventuellement pour faire
en sorte que ce centre ville qui
existent pour des raisons économiquement
très importante retrouve son art son
erre d'aller
il ya quelques secteurs évidemment le
tourisme évidemment les lignes aériennes
secteur aéronautique
ça va nous prendre des idées des
approches sectorielles les restaurants
la gastronomie il ya quelques secteurs
où il faudra être très attentifs michel
leblanc
merci beaucoup merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit